avos titienne sq la manoeuvre russe n'a
pas fonctionné comme prévu
plusieurs tanks et véhicules blindés
russes sont remorqués ainsi qu'une
tourelle de char les soldats russes ont
décidé d'attaquer ici par une des routes
principales les soldats russes ont
réussi à entrer dans cette ville comme
en témoignent leurs véhicules militaires
carbonisé ils sont restés ici trois
jours avant de battre en retraite vitaly
a participé à la bataille on les a tapé
près du pont baume là-bas beau mais
assez vite c'en était fini de leurs
colonnes l'ukraine était à nous est
allouée sera nous ils ont rien à faire
ici pendant trois jours les soldats
russes ont pris position dans les
maisons du quartier ça c'est leur
nourriture c'est écrit armées russes
ramon était alors au sous sol chez son
voisin
une fois revenu chez lui il a découvert
que les russes n'étaient pas reparti les
mains vides il était chez moi ils ont pu
manger ils ont tout retourné les
affaires des enfants les miennes il
devait chercher de l'argent de l'or je
n'en sais rien en tout cas ils ont volé
mais antidouleur mon parfum et de
l'alcool ils ont aussi pris mes outils
une clé à molette la clé en croix pour
la voiture et tous les outils
électriques pour tokyo à
son voisin de 80 ans rumine encore sa
colère ils ont roulé pour se mettre dans
la cour là la porte est cassé et là
aussi je ne l'aurais pas adressé la
parole car je n'ai rien à dire à ces
gens là
tout sauf que l'armée russe essayera de
re vous alors vous initier ce que se
tient prête
aux avant postes le maire de trente deux
jeunes entrepreneurs avant son élection
ils se forment désormais à la tactique
militaire on a fait sauter les ponts
mais on sait que l'ennemi peut traverser
la rivière alors avec des entrepreneurs
on a déterré ce côté de la rivière
fielding seulement 20 heures avant que
l'ennemi approche de la ville pour que
les tanks et les blindés ne passe pas
il s'en serait bien passé mais savent
ils présentent un intérêt stratégique
si mikko live au sud fait sauter ses
ponts il n'y a pas d'autres rues pour
aller à odessa ou kiev la capitale
seulement par notre ville donc on se
prépare à revoir les nuits la deuxième
centrale nucléaire la plus puissante du
pays est également à 30 km le jeune élu
le sait les russes ne renoncerons pas à
cet objectif